[Musique]
c-snot peut être une combinaison de choses,
y compris les restes de matériaux provenant d'
organismes marins en décomposition et leurs
matières fécales c-snot est scientifiquement
appelé mucliage marin
car il s'agit d'une combinaison de
substances ressemblant à du mucus afin de faire
un géant
mer booger
[Musique]
c-snot a un effet dévastateur sur
les autres espèces marines, il peut étouffer et
tuer le corail, il tue les éponges, il pénètre
dans les branchies des poissons
pour certains coquillages lorsqu'ils s'ouvrent,
ils cessent de ne pas être pris à l'intérieur et
ensuite ils peuvent '  t se refermer
et il peut également véhiculer des maladies qui peuvent
être transmises à des personnes
comme le choléra
[Musique]
malheureusement, la mer d'Amara est la
tempête idéale pour une épidémie saisonnière,
non seulement des eaux usées non traitées y ont été
déversées pendant 40 ans,
mais aussi  exposés au
ruissellement agricole pendant des décennies
qui, combinés à la hausse des températures de la mer
due au changement climatique,
nous donnent le résultat que nous voyons aujourd'hui,
des événements similaires se sont produits partout dans le monde,
y compris en Floride, dans le golfe du Mexique,
même à Hawaï,
mais ce qui se passe actuellement dans
la mer d'Amara est le  la plus grande épidémie
de csnot
jamais enregistrée
comme nous l'avons vu dans d'autres parties du
monde la morve de mer peut être nettoyée
ils utilisent essentiellement un très grand
aspirateur marin pour aspirer toute cette morve
malheureusement dans la mer d'amara il
y a des rapports qu'il n'y a pas de cesse  jusqu'à
deux mètres de profondeur
et cela va prendre plus qu'un
aspirateur marin pour nettoyer
[Musique]
si les problèmes de base ne sont pas traités
comme dans les eaux usées non traitées, le
ruissellement agricole et le changement climatique,
alors nous allons juste voir continu
et des quantités croissantes d'épidémies de csnot
[Musique]